einen regulären schulbetrieb gab es hier
zuletzt vor fünf monaten
die gemeinschaftsschule im thüringischen
triptis arbeitet im dauer notbetrieb
der gesamte landkreis ist corona hotspot
sieben tage incidents 558 bundesweit
rekord wie in allen schulen ist ein
corona schnelltest hier pflicht
zweimal die woche damit sollen corona
ausbrüche rechtzeitig verhindert werden
hier verbinden die kinder rutscht es
anstelle der sonst üblichen nasenbohrer
tests eher unangenehm weil da das
ungewohnt sondern stäbchen unter die
zunge zu legen
aber irgendwie die testpflicht ist unter
eltern umstritten manche schicken ihre
kinder deshalb nicht mehr in die schule
berichtet der elternsprecher ich finde
die testpflicht notwendig wenn wir eine
infektionskrankheit eindämmen wollen
müssen wir wissen wo die abos sind
es gibt zum glück sehr sehr viel mehr
zustimmung als ablehnung aber die die
gruppe der älteren ist natürlich auch
stark polarisieren die testpflicht an
schulen sorgt für diskussionen manchen
sind die schnelltests nicht geheuer
es war mal zu hause machen könnte ok ja
dann ist man als eltern mit dabei
man kann das bei aufsichten man kann
gucken dass nichts passiert die
inhaltsstoffe für den test nicht und
zweitens warum muss mein kind getestet
ich denke auch dass das für die psyche
der kinder nicht gut ist für die schule
bedeutet schnelltests noch mehr
verwaltungsaufwand für unterricht und
kinder bleibt immer weniger zeit
hauptaugenmerk liegt momentan wirklich
darauf sich mit der pandemie die
situation zu beschäftigen ob das jetzt
das kümmern ist um diese tests wie sie
verteilt werden und wie die kollegen
damit arbeiten oder
ob es das lesen von irgendwelchen
verordnungen ist neuen verordnung die
relativ häufig kommen auch wenn für die
schnelltests unterrichtszeit draufgeht
der aufwand lohnt sich da sind sich
experten weitgehend einig schnellstes
erlauben uns frühzeitig zu erkennen der
ansteckend ist und wenn wir in der
schule wissen wer ansteckend es
verhindern wäre dass sich andere
anstecken und damit bekämpfen wir die
pandemie nicht nur in der schule sondern
in der gesamten gesellschaft ja auch in
kitas sind regelmäßige corona tests
möglich das zeigt dieses projekt im
nordrhein westfälischen solingen der
sogenannte body test stäbchen in der
nase rum gestochert werden der lolli
test kann viel spielerischer
durchgeführt werden weil einfach darauf
gelöscht werden kann
es wird ist eine hohe akzeptanz von
eltern und kindern und deshalb
bevorzugen wir gehen einfach die
abgerutschten lollis kommen in ein gefäß
das ist der sogenannte pool der geht per
kurier ins labor und wird mit pcr
technik untersucht dies besonders
sensibel und zuverlässiger als antigen
schnelltest sieben stunden nach proben
eingang können sie davon ausgehen dass
das ergebnis berichtet wird an den
einsendern bislang war nur ein prozent
der solinger lolli tests positiv nur
dann untersucht das labor auch die
einzelproben so wird das infizierte kind
gefunden eltern kita und gesundheitsamt
informiert die entnahme des schmeckt
hervorragend geeignet
dass man das ganze sehr schnell
absolviert in der kita gruppe oder eben
halt in der grundschulklasse die
erzieher oder lehrer müssen das ganze
mehr oder weniger nur beaufsichtigen
jetzt kündigt die landesregierung an der
lolli test mit pc herkommt
flächendeckend an grundschulen in
nordrhein westfalen berlin
im kit kat club gibt es derzeit keine
partys sondern schnelltests das ergebnis
schon nach 20 minuten aber wie
zuverlässig ist dass dieses gefühl von
sicherheit dann doch ein stück weit ich
glaube das stimmt
viel zu häufig vermittelt ein negativer
schnelltest eine falsche sicherheit über
den tag hinaus so berichtet das robert
koch-institut zitat 67 prozent der
befragten nahmen an dass sie nach einem
negativen schnelltest ergebnis auch am
nächsten tag sicher nicht für andere
personen ansteckend sein können so wie
der schwangerschaftstest heute mir nicht
sagen kann ob ich in zwei monaten
schwanger bin so kann mir der antigen
schnelltest heute nicht definitiv sagen
ob ich morgen anstecken bin
denn ein guter antigen schnell test
erkennt zwar wenn ein mensch viele
corona viren in sich trägt und
ansteckend ist
dann zeigt er mit großer
wahrscheinlichkeit positiv
aber wenn ein mensch frisch infiziert
wurde
dann braucht das virus mehrere tage um
sich im körper zu vermehren
in den ersten tagen der infektion zeigt
der schnelltest negativ auch wenn man
schon einen tag später hoch ansteckend
ist
trotzdem gilt mancherorts der
schnelltest als schlüssel zur lang
ersehnten freiheit tübingen etwa setzt
dem lockdown ein hände öffnet im märz
den einzelhandel theater und
außengastronomie vertraut dabei auf
verpflichtende schnelltests die tests
nicht zuverlässig deswegen bin ich
optimistisch dass wir damit wenig oder
gar keine infektionen einschleppen
außerdem gilt ja weiterhin abstand maske
hygiene da machen wir keine abstriche
das tübinger modell beginnt am 15 märz
mit einer inzidenz von nur 20
infizierten pro 100000 einwohner mit
öffnungen und schnelltests steigt diese
zahl stark an die stadt muss lockerungen
zurücknehmen schließlich die bundes
notbremse die inzidenz liegt zuletzt bei
1 114
die fallzahlen sind gestiegen dennoch
sieht tübingens oberbürgermeister boris
palmer sein modell als erfolg
wo man kann argumentieren dass die
zahlen in tübingen viel weniger
angestiegen sind als im schnitt von
baden württemberg oder im umland von
tübingen und das deutet darauf hin dass
wir sogar infektionen verhindern konnten
fest steht mehr corona fälle bedeuten
mehr cupid patienten
anfang märz werden vier kurven patienten
invasiv beatmet im gesamten landkreis
tübingen
ende vergangener woche sind es 19 es ist
naiv zu glauben bei hohen zahlen das
virus weg leisten zu können
das gelingt nicht und das sehen sie auch
aktuell in verschiedenen regionen
unseres landes das funktioniert nicht
noch eine dieser regionen das saarland
dessen ministerpräsident tobias hans
sorgt für öffnung dann schnelltests und
scheitert das saarland experiment
beginnt mit einer sieben tage incidents
von 82 im zuge der öffnungen mit
schnelltests steigt die fallzahl
kontinuierlich an
bis auf 145 wie alles im leben muss man
erst mal eine maßnahme ergreifen und
schauen dass sie auch wirkt bevor man
dann in die belohnung geht öffnungen
können eine super belohnung sein wenn
eine breite test strategie aufgeht
schnelltests sind alltag geworden sie
helfen auf dem weg zurück in die
freiheit
das allheilmittel sind sie aber nicht
[Musik]